welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and this is another
edition of the
graduate entry-level podcast series
where we interview recruiters who are
early on in their recruitment career to
find out how it's going
what they might be doing what they might
have told themselves to do things
differently if they're to start over
again the challenges that they're
working through
and advice for those that are
considering a career in recruitment
or are still early on in their career as
well
really excited to be joined by danielle
today who are going to get to
introduce herself in a second but
really looking forward to another
edition of this episode so danielle over
to you
and then we'll get into the questions
hi hisham thanks for that introduction
so yeah i'm danielle blake
i have been in recruitment for coming up
to my seventh month now so
pretty new to all this still and i work
for a company called understanding
recruitment we're based in
albans and we also have teams in boston
too
um i specialize in the dotnet domain so
dotnet specialist recruitment for tech
so software developers
engineers and etcetera and i recruit
permanent positions as well
perfect and then further so you and you
graduated in two
last year yeah graduated in 2020 but
still haven't actually had my graduation
yet so oh wow
the grads at the moment we're just kind
of we have the piece of paper but never
actually graduated officially ah
okay and then cool so obviously been in
recruitment for
obviously seven yeah seven going on
eight months and then
just just for like context with people
so when did you when did you enter the
the world of work like after graduate so
when did you actually graduate what was
the month
so theoretically my graduation was in
july last year
i literally had a recruitment job
secured back from february in 2020 but
that got pulled out from under my feet
due to the pandemic so i was like
what do i do from here um all i wanted
at that point was a job
so i went into kind of a finance
position for a few months really
realized it wasn't for me and as soon as
i saw
kind of recruitment companies starting
to hire again
i got my foot straight back in that door
and first company i applied to was
understanding recruitment
got the job and so happy since
i love that so i'm excited to unpack
this then so
where i want to start is like so it
seems like he was really quite
intentional on recruitment it seems
it seems like like so i guess what i
want to find out from you is
one why did you want to get into
recruitment if you did
or and then two how has it been
compared to what you expected
okay so i guess initially i really
wasn't sure why i wanted to get into
recruitment so it got to kind of my
final year of university looking at the
november december time
when i started actually thinking what am
i going to do when i leave here
so i was you know starting applying to
here there and everywhere i did a
business management and marketing degree
so i was like okay
start looking at marketing pr sales
recruitment
anything under the sun in sales really
got into a few interview processes and
it really started becoming
very clear to me quite early on in these
processes
that companies may look really cool and
interesting on paper
really inviting but when you actually
get into the interview
it's a whole different world so for me
it came down to
what interviews i really enjoyed the
most and where i actually saw my career
developing and progressing
the most which i think is a really key
element for a lot of grads now we're not
just looking for jobs we're looking for
that progression development
ways to really push our career forwards
so
those recruitment interviews that were
the most interesting to me they were
engaging
informative culturally i felt like i
fitted in well and that was something i
found really really important
i mean you'll get to know me over this
podcast i'm very chatty
i'm very careful and communication is
probably one of my better traits so i
love speaking to people
being on the phone building
relationships and i really fell in love
with i mean this company in particular
understanding recruitment
but like the culture it really promotes
to how i and from there that was how i
directed kind of what company i was
looking to work for
yeah nice it just it seems like then was
really open-minded to like what you
wanted like oh yeah you just
tried you like experimented you went
into different instead of like
yeah i like that because what you're
just putting yourselves you're putting
yourself in a position to be like you
know what
i actually really like the sound of that
i like the people that i'm going to give
that a go
rather than like sitting at home trying
to find like the perfect job description
that you think you can do
you like went to interviews that maybe
you thought maybe maybe i could do that
maybe i couldn't and then
once you've got a grasp of it then you
made a decision
so you took action yeah so if you
haven't really got any kind of
commercial experience in the sector i
mean i've done some pr internships
didn't think it was the route i wanted
to go down but as a
student and going to be fresh graduate
what i was looking for were just those
opportunities that were there and i
could fit into
so i just kind of took every opportunity
that was available to me
and went through all these processes
because if you don't try you're not
going to succeed there's nobody going oh
maybe i'll like it maybe i won't so i
just won't apply
yeah yeah exactly and like it's just
very easy to like sit at home
and like look at find reasons why you
couldn't do that job or
when you don't feel when you haven't
like got the experience or whatever but
yeah okay so
what so now being in recruitment then so
like what skills or experiences
recruitment giving you that maybe you
you least expected
so every recruitment interview you're
going to get asked about resilience and
tenacity
and being a uni student i was like why
is this so important in
the world like what is this this kind of
push on resilience and tenacity
and kind of going into recruitment
you'll be dealing with rejected offers
candidates being under offered people
not answering the phone or answering
your messages
not turning up to interview there's so
many mix of things that can happen
which can throw all of your hard work
out the window saying being able to
manage that and on your own those
clients and calendars expectations it's
a huge feat itself
so kind of being able to do that and not
get yourself down is a really kind of
key aspect that
you don't really think about as much
until you're in the industry as oh i'm
going to build this much i'm going to
place this many people
you can only control so much in this
these jobs so it's kind of leaving that
ability to
trust people in the process but also
control what you can
and that really does focus in that
resilience and tenacity i mean
since being in recruitment i've learned
to control the processes
deal with the rejections and move past
it i think every uni student will say oh
i've got
great time management skills i can
complete courseworks to time
but until you enter an industry or into
recruitment
all these words like time management and
organizational skills are really just
too easily thrown about
so i mean there really is what i least
expected i guess it's definitely that
skill of being resilient
being able to confidently speak to
professionals and sectors that i've
never worked in and barely understood
myself i mean
i'm really very technically proficient
you could ask anyone in my industry but
it's the market i recruit into and all i
have done is i've taught myself these
elements that
i need to be conversational about and
that's kind of how you build up your
strengths with that resilience as well
yeah i love that so what
so having spoken to a couple of people
now
it seems like what you would have had to
tap into then and people
will have to tap into when they're early
on in this journey is
is their motivation so you're talking
about resilience there so i guess what
when you do have those knockbacks when
you have experienced those sort of
challenging times so far
what have you tapped into or like what's
like helped you remain motivated out of
interest
i guess for me understanding that i mean
the big thing is
you can only control the controllables
and the big thing for me was
taking that to an understanding that i
like being in control knowing exactly
what's going on when
and knowing exactly when my candidates
are interviewing exactly when they're
going to be calling me feedback
when offers are going to be going
through time frame specifics
and it is quite hard to tap into that
appreciation that
you can't control everything it's not
down to you at the end of the day
so that was kind of quite a big thing
for me without resilience and i managed
it because
i mean at the end of the day i was like
look candidates aren't going to want to
accept a job
that isn't in their best interest so i
made it a really big thing for me when
i'm speaking to canada say look
at the end of the day this isn't the
right position for you
don't go through the interview process i
don't want to waste your time
you don't want to waste my time and it's
not worth the outcome
so i really tap into kind of their
personality and their personal thoughts
of what they're looking for because if
it's
not exactly right for them or not
something they're keen on
there's no point pushing someone in
something where they're not even going
to pass their rebate period so all your
hard work's out the window anyway
sure so so the so you so obviously what
you've really had to learn and
really what you focus on is yeah
controlling the controllables which
helps
but i guess um i guess what i was just
trying to get from you is like what
what's helped you
remain motivated if you get what i mean
if yeah
if things have gone wrong like have you
then gone like have you have you
made the time to think about you know do
you have goals that you think about
or like i don't know just i guess things
that can help people listen to this that
they may have not made the time to think
about why i'm actually doing this job or
why am i in recruitment because
if if you if you don't really think
about that or haven't got much clarity
on that it can be very easy to get
bogged down in the
day-to-day or like really like those
setbacks really affect you
so i guess that's what yeah so like what
yeah i guess coming in i was thinking
these setbacks would have affected me a
lot more than they do and you'd really
have to be
mindful to not take anything too
personally i mean if someone's rejecting
enough
it's not because they don't like you
it's because it's not the right job for
them
so i mean don't get me wrong i've had my
fair share of rejected offers
dropped out candidates i mean my first
ever placement dropped out on the day he
was meant to start
and i was like oh well that's fine on to
the next and my manager looked at me
like
took that mentality and i was like well
if he's not going to go in there i'm
going to find someone else who is and
who's going to
make me that money at the end of the day
so like to me it was
just not taking that too personally
appreciating
it is just a challenge of the job and if
you can't accept that challenge
maybe recruitment isn't the best pathway
for you i mean you have to appreciate
there are challenges in any job
and rejection is one of them in
recruitment i mean so if you have a
really good and well-structured team who
manages your expectations you know what
you're going for and they're really
there to support you
that's the most important thing i mean
like my managers and my colleagues by my
side who are like
oh no that's awful don't worry we'll let
us go up for lunch
i'm like yeah sure but i'm just gonna
make a few calls and get a few people in
the interview process first in this role
you have to kind of keep that tenacity
with you and that's why it is so
important to
to not get bogged down by things because
that's things i'll ask you an interview
what if this happens what are people at
100 grand kind of salary placement
and they dropped out the day before what
are you gonna do
you'd be sad for five minutes you go get
a coffee and you get over it because
that is
part of the job where does this come
from where does this come from for you
then because this is a great
mindset and talking about resilience
talking about bouncing back you're
talking about
yeah self-awareness having a growth
mindset like where
have you always been this way i feel
like i have always been this way i'm
i'm a very kind of straight thinking
person i'm like
i might be my end goal is the money the
commission the promotion the incentives
like
hitting kind of incentive lunches half
year trips holidays
that's what i'm looking for at the end
of the day i want to be a top biller in
my company i want to be progressing i
want to be getting promoted i want to be
like
mentoring juniors and interviewing them
for to come into our company and why
because
i'm good at what i do i know what i do
and i love my company
and so not only do i want to make the
money for myself but
i also want to kind of perform well in
my industry and in my company i mean i
have no desire to leave to go anywhere
else and to make money for any other
company
so i'm staying where i am performing my
hardest doing my best
and like negative things happen it's
life i mean if you've been
through the last war you know that bad
things happen and whatever like
people haven't had their final year of
university they haven't graduated
they've been working from home with
online exams i mean
nearly the first three months of my
recruitment career i was working from
home and i was seeing all these
challenges
of me not learning as much and not
developing in my own areas
and you just have to accept it for what
it is and if you don't and you let
yourself get bogged down by all these
things
that's going to stunt your growth and if
you want your growth stunted
let it affect you but if you want to
progress you move forward
pretty easily and that's why i'm seeing
a lot of people in my industry and
company as well are doing i mean
you get a dropper you get a rejected
offer and you're on to the next five
minutes later
no one really lets it affect them it
can't be a personal matter
love it so what so what advice
would you give them for people that
obviously you're you're still in this
life
the first first year of your uh
recruitment career
so i guess thinking about if i'm
listening to this and i might be
starting a recruitment job
sooner or i'm like in maybe the first
couple of months
like what what advice would you give to
people that are at that stage like
really early on where you was knowing
what you know now
okay so definitely kind of at that
application stage
apply to everything and anything that
you think could interest you
because even if the day if you don't get
the job or you don't like the process
you will learn so many skills just by
interviewing
companies throughout the process whether
it's how to perform with recruitment
how to do role plays how to present
yourself and come across an
interview i remember my first interview
i was so nervous
and our hands were sweaty i was like
deodorant spraying my hands because i
think this one wants to shake my hand
what am i gonna do
and that was my first interview by the
time i got into the second third
fourth interview with the same company
different companies i had my like
process
down i knew how to present myself how to
hold myself
i learned how to perform in role plays
and to manage tricky questions
so that's kind of one but i'd also
really recommend doing your due
diligence
if you're interested in a company do
your research before that interview
go in with questions you want to ask
things you already know about the
company that you want to delve into
deeper
everyone loves a candidate who's done
their research no matter what industry
no matter what company
so that's kind of really important as
well and then i guess finally i'd say
look into that cultural environment make
sure they're key questions that you are
asking so i mean i appreciate some
companies
do have much more of a work from home
policy now so culture and environment
may not be as much of a large factor but
i mean where i ended up
my old job the culture made me hate
going into work every day the
environment was so uncomfortable for me
that i wanted to work from home
and understanding recruitment i have no
desire to work from home i
love being in the office i love being
around the people i'm with
so if the working environment isn't
enjoyable there's no morale the people
you don't enjoy being there why would
you as well i mean i entered a row i
hated
during the pandemic i put my initial
graduate role from under my feet as i
mentioned from
from a different recruitment company and
it wasn't my old job itself that i
didn't like
it was the people and the culture and
that made me not want to perform
it made me not want to be in the office
so at the end of the day
the happier you are the better your work
and your work life will be
hmm love that and then what so just on
this and then keen to get your like
thoughts on if people are sort of in
their first year as well what
things have helped you or what advice
you'd give but how
would be your advice for people to stand
out then
in like because as you know be super
competitive there'd be loads of
graduates or
people trying to enter um the workforce
for the first time like what
like obviously now being in recruitment
or give in prepping people for
interviews and stuff like that like what
what can people do listening to this to
stand out amongst the the competition
okay so prior to obviously having that
job if you're at university or you're a
student
of any form go and get internships
apprenticeships band ambassador roles
for
any company it doesn't matter where
because most of them you will be selling
of some sort if you're not being paid
you're not being paid you're a student
at the end of the day it's not ideal but
in order to get that experience before
you go into your first proper work
placement
i definitely recommend kind of any of
those internships apprenticeships
online courses something extracurricular
that's not
oh at uni i did this because everyone
did something at uni how to make sure
it's
outside of that element and be open to
really everything's the key to like a
graduate success for me
is to really continuously learn be that
sponge soak everything up that anyone
tells you because
something you think could be irrelevant
four months down the line be like oh
i remember someone said to me once and
it will kind of come to fruition and be
kind of beneficial to you um and i mean
in recruitment there isn't really a set
way that anyone works that is the same
so
going into a role that you don't know or
an industry you don't know you will find
your own structure or plan that works
best for you
and i guess for kind of preparing for
these interviews and things like that
you need to be prepared especially in
many sales jobs
be prepared for that hard work long
hours rejection if you can take those
things
recruitment's for you so if you've got
an experience where you've been knocked
down before
where you've had a challenge where
science really not gone your way
put that forward in an interview and say
how you've moved past that and overcome
it because overcoming challenges
is a really big kind of there's a really
big aspect of sales positions and
interviewers will really kind of
appreciate that
and i guess finally something i learned
early on is no question is a stupid
question i mean i say to manage about
four times a day
stupid question but because coming from
an industry i had no idea
that there are a million things i didn't
know about and to be honest there are
still a lot of things i don't know seven
months in
the best way to improve and learn is to
ask and if you don't ask you don't get
and you won't know
yeah i love that so talk to me about
what have been
because obviously you strike me
something that's like super positive
which i love but like what have been
some of your biggest challenges so far
then in
seven eight months of working in
recruitment
oh biggest challenges okay um
so i think i think for me and for like
initial graduates entering a company a
new market itself can just be a
challenge i mean i'm not very
technically proficient i can barely work
a computer
i barely could before i started here
have you learned how have you learned
then how have you got yourself
comfortable in dealing with people that
are
the opposite of that practice you just
practice i mean you get yourself on the
phone and you start speaking to people
if there's some if i'm speaking to
someone about technology that i haven't
really spoken someone about before i'm
not really well versed in
what platforms they'd be using you're on
how it will change their workflow how
it'll
improve like the company aspect i will
ask them i'll say
thanks x for your time i can see you've
worked with i don't know
aws cloud just for example something i
actually haven't come across too much
with developers can you tell me a bit
about your work with that
and your projects and 99.9 the time
people who are confident in these
technologies are really willing to talk
about them because it's where they're
comfortable
so i mean i guess it's also that thing
that
as i'm not the most proficient
individual recruiting in tech and
software it took me a while to
understand my market and actually get
confident with it
but the more you just pick up the phone
and pretend it's not a big deal
the less of a big deal it'll become i
mean i just acted more confident than i
actually was when i was speaking to
people i pretended i knew what i was
talking about
and from that you actually learn more
than you realize
and also kind of listening to other
people's conversations and how they
manage the flow i mean i have google
alerts coming to my email every day on
net news so i there'll be recent tech
releases
um updates i'll post on linkedin about
it to make some credible posts for my
my kind of network and by kind of doing
all these
little bits of asking the questions
reading an article a few times a week
posting on linkedin commenting on
people's posts you learn
so many things that defeat those
challenges of i don't understand this
space
i'm really new here because you're
continuously learning and every day
you'll pick something new up that you
don't realize
any other challenges um i mean worried
about speaking on the phone in front of
your peers for the first time doing
business development
yeah bd definitely stressed me out and
was a challenge to me i mean i think
i might done my first like four months i
started feeling really confident and
being on the phone
sourcing and kind of focusing on that
candidate side recruitment and as i
started feeling comfortable they were
like right danielle we're moving you
into bg
and that kind of threw me straight off
the bus i was like right i just felt
comfortable
he was trying to throw me under the bus
again so it was a really stressful time
to
i basically have cut my sorting time in
half now because i spent half my time in
the week
focusing on client side so that
definitely was a really big challenge
to kind of break into especially when i
still feel so new in the market
but at the same time if you're not
pushing yourself you're not learning and
developing so it's just something you
accept you move on
you kind of structure your days really
really kind of focused with
time frames per task and that kind of
helps you overcome that stress because
when you're so busy
and you have a million things to do in a
day you need to prioritize those
so you're actually doing the most
important things and if it gets to six
six thirty seven and you haven't sent a
cv
is it the worst thing if you write that
cv up tomorrow morning probably not
but if you haven't done your bd for the
day that's going to affect your bd for
the next day
um how would you describe your first
couple of bd
sessions then because they were
definitely daunting for me oh my god so
daunting um
i was because i felt comfortable
speaking to technical people on the
phone i was like right the people i'm
going to focus my connections with
are these head of software header
technology engineering managers ctos i
try to stay a bit away from talent
people at first because
if you message a recruiter and you say
oh i want a job they're going to go
we're internal no thanks but if you
would have pushed things into
i mean the way we really structure our
bds we have a kind of a lot of processes
involved in medium we also have a lot of
content already set up within each
vertical
i mean we have a net report per year
that we amend and rewrite
we have women in diversity um inclusion
kind of report for your bd
yes we use our kind of we have dot net
specialist content we will send out to
people who are focused
in like the heads of or the heads of
software engineering managers
and that's how we try and reel them in
by not just saying oh we want a job
we say i have something that could help
you what are your thoughts without even
asking for a job you don't mention
what job's on at the moment if they do
you just say this the market i
specialize with
i can see your and i don't know
financial services here are some of the
partners the clients i've partnered with
over the past x amount of months we've
placed x amount of candidates there
um they were actually really struggling
with this technology
we found this manage that so you
basically kind of
go in with something that is going to
create a relationship
automatically without actually asking
for jobs because i mean a lot of
recruiters are going to go in and go
okay i'm a dot-net specialist can i have
every job you have please and no one is
going to give you that
you need to build a relationship what's
the bet that companies had
five six other messages this week saying
the exact same thing
so you do need to approach it in a
different way to how my is my brain
initially thought
okay you going hi how are you i
specialize in.net
saw you advertising role think i can
help everyone's going to say that and it
took me kind of a few training sessions
to realize
how the other ways i can go about that
are so well initial connections
commenting on posts really increasing
that engagement
so bd was definitely a huge challenge
for me when i kind of first started i
mean it still is a challenge just by
speaking to clients arranging things
negotiating fees it's all a bit
stressful i'm going to be completely
honest
really enjoyable and when someone comes
back to yours actually yeah i'd really
love to arrange a call you think
wow this company actually found what
i've i've given them really interesting
and potentially
we can help them way other agencies
haven't so it's a stressful situation
but it really has its bonuses
but i'd say challenge-wise it's just one
of those things that when you come in as
a resourcer you don't know what you're
doing and you have to learn the ropes
so when you move into bg it's the exact
same it's not
experienced with you just learn the
ropes you learn the processes
and it's a trial and error situation
there's going to be failures there's
going to be wins
yeah i think um it's just weird because
like for me thinking back it was always
like
it was like this thoughts before i made
the calls or
like so when i actually got through to
someone i spoke to someone like it was
fine
and like i sort of was able to
build rapport or like make that call go
in
normally like a good way but it's always
like the bit leading up to that cool
where you're like
oh what what's going to happen if this
person picks up and all that to go i
mean but then when you're actually on
the call it's fine so and then you get
off it's like
why did i pick that up as such a big
deal like just
yes it is funny um
so i've got two last questions for you
so one
just for people listening to this that
may be hiring for their business hiring
for their teams
and most of these people will would love
to have people like you in their
business
young motivated positive sort of
attitude um and like
what i just want to hear from you and
it's what i did a
post about today but like from your
perspective
you your friends etc like what what is
it that
young people actually want out of
recruitment business like what are they
motivated by like what actually gets
them going
like is it the holiday incentives and
these types of things or is it bigger
than that like i don't know like what
really
i guess connected with you and what do
you think would connect with other
younger people that you think is really
important to them
um okay so i mean there's so many
incentives and benefits and you hear
about sales jobs whether it's
recruitment or any other sales kind of
role itself i mean yes you've got a
basic salary and a basic salary
if you go into an instagram yeah i want
to earn 23 grand a year that would be
great for me
you're never going to get a sales job
you walk and you go okay i saw the basic
salary
but i'd love to kind of see my own
target earnings at this
year how am i going to get there so of
course commission is quite
an important factor in in recruitment or
sales positions because
you are looking for that commission
you're looking for
the extra money the progression the
career development
but yeah so money's obviously a great
incentive for any sales position because
i mean
i'm not looking at 60 70 80 000 pound
basics like our developers are in my
roles for example
but i mean especially coming out of the
pandemic or anyone who's had a job
before in a kind of a sales environment
there's usually quite a lot of
progression that they do provide you and
i mean me coming out of uni i was i want
a job i'm going to start in
i'm going to progress through the ranks
and give me a few years i'll be managing
people or kind of mentoring more junior
people
why do you care about that though why is
that important like why does that get
you going why does that
motivate you why is that within my
market i mean we see people move from
company to company every
18 months to two years i've never
thought of myself
as a jumpy person i've always seen
myself to go into one company
and be there for like a really extensive
period of time like find that company
that fits
me and who i am and my values
and if you find a company that matches
your values and everyone in that company
has the same values there's no way
you're not gonna a learn be develop
yourself professionally and
personally and also kind of really enjoy
what we're doing so i mean i
i know realistically everyone spends the
next 40 odd years of their lives working
at least 10 hour days and if i'm going
to be doing that i'm going to be doing
that and a company that i absolutely
love and see my career like absolutely
skyrocketing from
and that was what i've really found with
understanding recruitment i mean they
have a really big focus on culture
they have a really big focus on teamwork
and i don't want to be in a company
that's i mean you hear recruitment being
dog-eat-dog and
everyone take candidates from each other
and rolls from each other and stab each
other in the back and
that was why i was a bit questionable
about recruitment at the beginning in
some of these really large organizations
then looking to understanding
recruitment you have that really kind of
team culture fit where
everyone celebrates everyone whether
it's big ones or super small wins
they'll support you through your losses
they'll support you through anything
and that is the most important thing
because having that support
helps you learn it helps you develop i
mean i had a bit of a
a crappy day like one day last week one
of my coins was like oh let's let's go
for a five minute walk we'll
chat about what's just gone on then
we'll come back with a fresh head and
that was exactly what
we did we took 10 minutes out of the day
we went for a walk to refresh our mind
because if you're sitting there at your
desk
you're not going to be doing anything
productive or kind of beneficial to
yourself or kind of getting
anything going further than any other
processes so
yeah i mean there's obviously that
progression which is really key i wasn't
looking for
something that's just going to be a
dead-end job i was looking for something
that's going to push me
in my personal and professional
development i've got the option of um
obviously obviously passivation then you
hit promotions you hit
half year trips full year trips there's
monthly like restaurant incentives in my
company
and all those things they push you to
make want to make yourself better
make you want to work harder and have
these better outcomes but everyone's
really supportive with it
which is what i really appreciate is
that great mix of you've got this sales
environment where you're working hard
and whatever
but you've also got that environment of
supportiveness and kind of collaboration
which i think is really important for me
nice i love that so final question why
obviously typically hear recruitment
being an accident a career that people
fall into like why do you think people
should consider recruitment as a career
choice
well this one i mean there's a million
reasons okay so of course
every company is different where i am
understanding recruitment
again you've got those financial
incentives you've got moving further
than just commission i mean you've got
half year trips full year trips holidays
half days off whole days off
team incentives well-being days and it's
a type of company that or
any company that has kind of really
collaborative culture like this is that
they see you working hard and they want
to kind of reward you for that
so if you want to go into a career where
you're going to be working hard you'll
be pushing yourself to the limits yeah
you might be working 12-hour days some
weeks
but is it something that you love to do
yes
cool is sale something you love or do
you love speaking to people do you love
being conversational
all these things for me were yeses so i
could have gone into marketing
who kind of had the same client
relationships but
not really kind of seen as much on this
this financial benefit side not as much
kind of
progression into where i see myself
going i mean i've been in recruitment
for six months and i probably get head
hunted
three four times a week by different
companies because they're like
we see your experience we'd love to have
that here
well how can you see that in six months
i'm thinking i think
that just shows how much i can learn
from december to now
i mean if you have that learning mindset
you can
appreciate being a sponge for a brit and
sucking everything in
that's kind of way or looking and i mean
i was looking for clear progression i
wanted to know
how often people were getting promoted
how common it was for people to get
promoted in their first year
i kind of the development these
companies are focusing on quite heavily
i mean from my personal experience
we have a fantastic training team here i
mean i have kind of bds
training like once a week and if i want
more i can book in individual sessions
if i just wanted some extra development
and training purposes
i can have that here so that in-depth
training really helps to better
understand your role the market
and it really kind of helps you focus on
that progression so i got a bit
comfortable in month four and i said oh
yeah i could i can source i can speak to
candidates i'm all good here
then they threw bd at me and i was like
oh wow like the progression i thought i
wanted is already here
and i thought it was going to be a few
months away so it really is so
fast-paced and you pick things up so
often that
progression is almost instant from being
in a company like this i mean
there's obviously the normal company
perks of why you want to be in
recruitment oh fun culture
pool table like whatever it's going to
be fully drinks fridge early finish
fridays but
i think for me the two the two main
things and why you should want to get
into a recruitment career
is a those monetary incentives and it's
not oh i want to go and buy myself a
pair of trainers and a handbag every few
months it's right
i want to move out in four years this is
how much i want to save in four years
and i'm going to make this many deals
and get this much commission in per year
so i can reach those goals it's those
long-term standing goals for one
and then of course i mentioned before
that progression and that clear kind of
pathway for you to develop yourself
personally and professionally
are really important and i don't think
many other sales industries give you
that is in such intensity
love it danielle i absolutely love your
energy excited to
sort of see your recruitment career
unfold and um
thank you so much for being involved
with the the podcast series
no no worries thank you so much for
having me it's been an absolute blast